Ehestreit Alkohol ein rätselhafter Sturz
der Tod von Sternekoch Heinz Winkler
wirft Fragen auf war es vielleicht gar
keine natürlicher Tod der Lieblingskoch
vom Chiemsee vieler Promis und auch
Politiker der Stab in der Nacht von
Freitag auf Samstag
Organversagen doch die genauen Umstände
die sind noch völlig undurchsichtig und
jetzt ermittelt sogar die
Staatsanwaltschaft
er träumte schon von der Rente auf
Mallorca suchte einen würdigen
Nachfolger als Küchenchef doch jetzt ist
Sternekoch Heinz Winkler Tod völlig
unerwartet im Alter von 73 Jahren sein
Tod wirft Fragen auf
was geschah in den letzten Stunden
Rückblick Aschau 27 Oktober Heinz
Winkler ist wie üblich in seiner
fünf-sterne-residenz kocht dort für die
Gäste unerwartet taucht Koch Sandro B
auf obwohl er nicht zum Dienst
eingeteilt war gegen 18.30 öffnen Sie
die erste Flasche Wein laut Angestellten
hat Winkler an diesem Abend viel
Redebedarf die Scheidung von seiner Frau
Daniela steht im Raum das Ehepaar habe
sich in dieser Woche heftig gestritten
ums Geld Ehefrau Daniela sei die
scheidungsabfindung zu gering nach
Bildinformationen will Winkler Aschau
verlassen und mit seiner jungen
Geliebten die er langer geheim gehalten
hat ein neues Leben im Ausland beginnen
dort sogar eine Kochschule eröffnen
gegen 21 Uhr ist Winkler stark
angetrunken Sandro bietet ihm anni nach
Hause zu fahren was dann geschieht weiß
nur Sandro B und er ist nicht
unumstritten von einem rauen Umgangston
in der Küche ist die Rede sogar Schläge
soll es von ihm gegeben haben doch damit
nicht genug sein Name taucht in der
Ermittlungsakte zum Unfalltod der damals
23-Jährigen Veronika 2019 auf die
stellvertretende rezeptionsleiterin in
Winklers Residenz wurde nach einer Disco
Nacht auf ihrem Nachhauseweg von einem
Auto totgefahren und Verdacht Sandro B
er saß damals sogar in Untersuchungshaft
das Strafverfahren wegen Fahrerflucht
mit Todesfolge wurde wegen mangelnder
Beweise eingestellt
doch was geschah am 27 Oktober diesen
Jahres kurz nach dem Winkler um San
tropez das Lokal verlassen kommt Sandro
B zurück und schreit der Heinz ist
gestürzt der Notarzt wird sofort
alarmiert Sandro B hat Blut an seiner
Kleidung nach bildnachfrage bestätigt
das Polizeipräsidium Oberbayern Süd wir
führen ein Todesermittlungsverfahren
dies ist bei einer unklaren Todesursache
ein ganz normaler Vorgang klar ist der
Tod von Sternekoch Heinz Winkler er
wirft viele Fragen auf jetzt entscheidet
der Staatsanwalt ob eine Obduktion
durchgeführt wird
[Musik]